صور مباشره للخبر الرئيس الذي خرجنا به في
هذه النشره والمتعلق بالعبوتين الناسفتين
اللتين تم تفجيرهما في القدس واحده في
مدخل القدس واخرى امام محطه للحافلات طبعا
المعلومات التي توفرت حتى الان هذه صور
مباشره كمان نشاهد لموقع التفجير
المعلومات التي توفرت حتى الان انه المفجر
والذي قام بوضع هذه العمليات قد وضع همم
تفجير عن بعد همم وايضا بانه كان يستقل
دراجه كهربائيه انتقل فيها من منطقه الى
اخرى يتم البحث هناك اجتماع امني نتنياهو
مع القيادات الامنيه لبحث ما جرى سؤال
كبير خاصه انه بالفتره الاخيره في الداخل
الفلسطيني كانت هناك عمليات فرديه اما هذه
العمليه كونها لم يشهد مثيلها منذ سنوات
اخر مره كانت في 2019 وكان ذلك في الضفه
همم الغربيه وليس في القدس فان ذلك يرفع
التساؤلات ان كانت هناك خلايا تعمل همم
طبعا لصنع هذه همم القنبله ومن ثم نقلها
الى داخل القدس حيث هناك اجراءات امنيه
مشدده اضافه الى الحديث ايضا عن ان هناك
من يمكن ان ننفذ هذه العمليه مستوى اخر
تدخل اليه العمليات في الداخل همم فلسطين
وطبعا هناك همم اجتماع امنيه كما ذكرنا
تعزيزات امنيه على الارض تحرك للمستوطنين
ايضا في الضفه الغربيه همم انتقاما طبعا
من المواطنين الفلسطينيين المدنيين لما
حدث من تفجيرات طبعا المواجهات مع
المستوطنين مستمره منذ فتره طويله ولكن
ارتفعت نسبتها بالفتره الاخيره وهي تعود
ايضا مجددا الان اذن صور مباشره مشاهدينا
لموقع احد الانفجاراين قرب مدخل القدس